こんにちは和美社長と5万ちゃんよりくんですはいはいえっとですねちょっと前にです
ね一句チョコをこの場所にしてまとめようって動画あったんですけども
ぞと唸っての割合の問題でまとまりませんでした茅野市まあなんかいろいろ食べたりし
てフライパンいっぱい以外の糧にあったんですけども
最終的に僕まとまっての法律論これを何とかしてまとめる方法を色々考えたんですけど
もうコメント欄を見た結果ですねやっぱりホットプレートで熱でまとめちゃった方が
いいのじゃないかと思っている
こちらのホットヴェイド入りました慎重にあっ
かダメダメ本当に帰ってきてホッとベイトは全部完了でございますでも入っていればさ
よだかってロボ子フレンズじゃねーよ
どうびっくりしたこれでは温まってるんでしょう正月くださいねいますだからねうん
ありますバッグあったかい
どっ
ちょっとつくねなんで全然まとまらなかったというとリップチョコって周りがチョコで
コーティングされているだけでもうなんか金全部砂ってなんですよですなくっていうの
はどれだけ全然頭とかで温めても固まることがないので今回ちょっといた息をズームし
ました
いた粒を入れてこのスナックとチョコの割合の都合の悪いの方ちょっと多くして固め
れるようにしますとりあえずマンやっていきましょー油を引いて
の子が減ら油麩を引いて焦げないようにしますチョコ入れてみよう
早い早いすごいすごいきたんじゃないと dic 茶農家が入れてきます
でも活動の主みたいの作っ買ってると思いません
現在ここをほじくっていきません
楽しかった
遺跡みたいだったら今度はこれがやばいの熱い的には問題ないですまだ全然食えます
それ前のかな
手を出すなってだったこのまばらに入ってる感覚っておいしいよ
でも結構ほりきてるんだけどまたちまって旨そうそうね全然くれる多分
今
まっチップはペアでや設計者やいる
いやこういったともいえそううまいまあまあ h マーサーちゃイヤー
f うまそうじゃねぇ
よ僕食べまして動い知ってさっほー
ね隕石じゃないかって言われと牛そ分
50たんだから野菜健康に火を止めてみましょう
またして方までがどうかですねポイントはみんな見た目的には認めてくれてみたみた
けど ok ですよ
綺麗な動画ですよ今日は確かにちょっと画面越しでだいぶんじゃないかもしれないです
けど一応モザイクかけとかこれ本来は丸い形でしたかったんですよねまてぃくないよね
秋鮭てきたパスを
マッハ
打つにネッツと超るぞこちらは打つぞと熱い歌じゃじゃーん
あ例えばちょっと弱いのかな方なってねーはい一夏ボーヴェに移したのでちょっと格好
を固めていきたいところだね
でももっとツボかんだしたよもっととか聡著
まずやばいやつみたいに居れずまずは見て来て前ですねちょっとちょっと少ないと思っ
たんでちょこ
ギターんん二つ落としていきますまあすごいよ
伸びて行ってみるかあの中国醸造いくおっ橋脚暴挙
ひとまずこれでまあされば一応全ての big チョコは福銀
まではいかないですけど食べられ形にはなったと思います
やばい落とせばやろうとしてますよそれにあまりだってゲームに出てるもちょっと戻す
じゃあメディアですよ板津怒ってるとかって言うかしてかしていたチョコっち済みでを
固めていくとしましょう年は
ああいい国調べるって言ってプレプレしてっ
10中の初めてこんなに調理器具粒の初めてなことで全部こっちで打ち終わったんで
板チョコをここで
なるべくとかしてそれをここに入れます以下にこの先いざそこで固めているかで決まり
ます
ございます
までのひとまずいた著効全部溶かしてこっち入ったんで
まずはこっちで一家に固められるかで決まります勝負は
パパ坊
あっはいいねばっ
葉っぱなかなかなくあらゆる手をつけトレ喚声刺されたような今回に関してはいっ
待て
ああ綺麗になってきたどうぞだ結構ワイド固まればいけそうな
ok 勝敗上記の無事とりあえず方までにはだったと思います
だけどこれを今から冷蔵庫にしやして固まってから食べようと思います子とかグリスに
ちょっと年末なんですと見に行こうと思います
別れなければ一番いいんですけどね
うざいが変わります